a shocking Dancing with the Stars
elimination
the couple leaving right now is Heather
and Max Heather Morrissey and Maksim
Chmerkovskiy sent home after receiving
the first perfect score of the season
and max his first week back after being
sidelined with an injury this was a very
shocking shocking turn of events well I
mean we had few of those in the 24
seasons of the show and I just never
thought that that you know one of my
couples is going to be part of that
shock this is crazy so that's why it's
kind of like it's almost okay because
it's so wrong you know in terms of dance
you don't really know what's coming next
so you know I was kind of preparing for
anything that could happen or come my
way and so it was kind of something that
I was like okay if this is gonna happen
like let's just be positive and let go
out the right way and was that because
we want to see him dance again you know
what I mean like it was it was nice to
get to be the last but like you want to
see him dance again come on I'm pissed
but yeah it's silly like I said before
it's not the last time with your stuff
together and you know looking forward to
when that happens
[Music]